welcome back now it's been economy week
in the campaign with both labour and the
Conservatives unveiling their spending
plans but how much of what they're
saying is actually sinking in and if it
is and what is the [ __ ]
well Skye's deputy political editor Sam
Coates is teaming up with a polling
company you got the selection to try and
spot the trends test what's working and
give us that bit of insight into what
might happen and he joins us now and so
Sam economy week we've heard from both
the Chancellor Sajid Javid and the money
wants this job Shadow Chancellor John
McDonald what's been going on so the
Labor Party have said that if they
entered anning street they will spend 55
billion pounds a year more on public
services the Tories are also going to
spend more 20 billion pounds a year but
for a reversal of their historic fiscal
conservatism austerity that message that
they've had since 2010 so let's have us
let's see what cutting through together
with you gov of we've partnered for this
election campaign we asked the public
what they believed would happen to the
economy depending on who want so the
first question we asked was if labor
forms of government do you think that
suspending would be the same go up or go
down of the labor party right
overwhelmingly you can see from these
numbers that people believe spending
will go up more than 50% believe that
with only a tiny number thinking that
all done that it'll go down and and but
roughly one in five saying they don't
know but but clearly that message has
broadly got through if you break down
how much you think that spending is
going to go up by then 35 percent say
that basically spending is going to go
up by much more so that key labor
message has got through to quite a lot
of members of the public now more
interestingly is the Conservatives why
is it more interesting because their
message is a new one because they have
effectively reversed their position in
the 2010 2015 election even 2017 they
had those tough fiscal rules how many
people have realized this well if you
look at it only thirty percent of the
population do you think that the Tories
will increase spending turn on those
spending taps a message that Boris
Johnson want to hammer home and there's
a lot of confusion culture them thinking
it won't increase and say the same
twenty familiar quarter of the
population that he'll go down and again
one in five don't know so all I would
gently
that that suggests that the Tory
campaign has quite a long way to go to
deliver you know there's no way the
economy isn't giving one of the biggest
reasons why people turn out and vote in
a particular way at this election so
they've got they've got some journey to
go it's interesting isn't because as you
say at the beginning yes labour spending
plans involve more money but both
parties are talking about some pretty
hefty sums I mean there's taps are
coming back on and you're like if you
say this I mean they're charts to it
themselves don't they you can see labor
here absolutely people think that they
can spend more and then open the
conservative corner a much more of a
split message how worried do you think
Boris Johnson is going to be if he has a
look at these two graphs here well I
think that there'll be some concern they
need to work on those don't knows and
really work on those people do you think
they'll cut spending there's a problem
here for the Conservatives some people
might have not heard the message yet but
given the Tories record back since 2010
some people might have heard the message
but not believe if that's what we asked
the question in this way do you think
that they will do what they say so some
work for CC HQ conservative headquarters
from this we also asked whether or not
they thought that Sajid Javid should be
Chancellor or John McDonald we made it
that sort of forced choice as it were
and Sanjay Javed comes out on ahead 22%
of the vote John McDonald on 13% but
look at this graph really this is a bit
of a plague on both of your houses
because neither comes out as inhe ahead
at 36% don't know at 29% so I did or
something I feel like that's a big shrug
of the shoulders from the electorate
about both choices and there's a
particular way we are able to break down
those numbers depending on by the way
that people voted in 2017 and we
discovered that in 2017 people who voted
Tory in 2017 just 31 percent of people
who voted labour in 2017 want John
McDonnell as Chancellor compared to 50%
who voted Tory who wants added Javid so
even people who are able to put an X in
the box for Jeremy Corbyn to come prime
minister appear appear
to have some doubts and why do you think
that is it's quite interesting isn't it
that even among labor supporters people
who in naturally perhaps voting labour
at the last time round they have some
concerns about John McDonnell me do you
think that is perhaps because people are
worried about labour spending too much
and we're looking at the grants early
weren't we where people really believed
that labour we're going to spend
considerably more money it's interesting
broadly speaking people do want more
spending on public services
that's what Labour are promising more
than the Tories and yet still there is
some doubt so I think that is an
interesting question to delve into in
the weeks ahead and really that brings
us to sort of the last big area the
question that everyone keeps asking
where are we now here is voting
intention this is you girls facing
intention going back to 2016 there's a
big picture here which is around the
time that Boris Johnson became prime
minister the Tories basically got back
quite a healthy pull lead and in the
last YouGov sky voting intention that
that lead is at 11 points which is you
know should should put the Tories on
calls for a majority if that's where we
ended up in five weeks time but if you
look at the next screen you can see you
know you got a number of one of a number
of polling companies if the if the Tory
leader is 11 points in YouGov it goes as
high as 16 in some polls and there's low
as seven in others that means there's a
huge amount of volatility and I think
the message more than anything else to
sort of Ram home at the moment is there
is uncertainty on both sides brexit
plans it's not clear that either of
their their detailed plans are
desperately popular with the public
there is clearly a long way to go on the
argument over the economy the economy
and brexit clearly going to be two of
the biggest things in this election and
there is big variation in the headline
voting intention polls at the moment
that would suggest that nothing is a
done deal the Tories might have wanted
this election because they were keen to
get on and maybe trying to feat Jeremy
Corbyn but it is not yet clear that
anybody knows what's going to happen on
December the 12th and do you think that
means as it did in the last election
that Therese may called
do you think that means that the
campaign matters perhaps more than ever
I think it does one of the interesting
features about this campaign is that
effectively you have two big new figures
who are both fresh on the political
scene Boris Johnson who although a
familiar figure well-known needs to
introduce himself to the public as Prime
Minister making promises people to
decide whether they believe him Joe
Swenson who also is new was elected over
the summer as a Liberal Democrat leader
is to introduce herself and one of the
big dynamics of this election is the
battle between the Labour Party and the
Lib Dem party for the remain voters
people have voted remain in 2016 that
could actually end up determining who
ends up going in number 10 on December
13th fascinating stuff and Sam thank you
so much for doing all the research and
for coming on to explain to us just how
much the campaign is going I certainly
feel a little bit more but I got an
insight into it so thank you very much